apple released the iphone 12 and i'm
literally
i think i'm going to skip it i i don't
feel the need to upgrade i think i'm
going to wait for iphone 13.
i wonder if they will come up with the
13 since it's an unlucky number i wonder
if the
what their plan there is if they're
going to skip it or not
but this is a bigger issue for apple the
most innovative product they've come out
with
since the iphone and the ipad
is airpods and airpods are wonderful and
amazing devices i think the watch
is you know it's it's done okay i'm not
a super fan of the watch
and so you have to wonder with apple
having declining
iphone sales the number of units
shipping has been going down year over
year over year
because there's really not that much
different about these phones
and i have to say i have i keep an uh
pixel
uh four around i always get an android
phone in the pixel 5.
those phones are as good or better
typically and they're certainly better
value for money
than the iphone and so
uh while i am still a fan of apple's
phone and it is still my default phone i
don't feel
the loyalty to apple i used to feel i
stopped buying their computers i went to
chrome
and i started using windows again and i
love my dell windows
and those machines are for the same
price i can get a machine that's like 50
or 100 more powerful uh when i buy a
dell
and really uh you have to wonder now
what is the future of apple if the most
innovative things they do
are around cost savings and logistics in
terms of
what we just saw with making the boxes
smaller like that's the announcement
or like colors like the different colors
of the iphone is something that steve
jobs did with the i
the ipod for those of you who are
generation c
ipod was a device like an iphone that
only did one thing play music and it
wasn't connected to the internet
um the ipod mini had all the different
colors like we we get it color and
the the original imac came in all the
different fruity colors like
we get it multiple colors gives you more
options and it's interesting